this video is brought to you by hover
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here and today
we're back to one of our favorite topics
anti-vaxxers now we've already talked
about some of the surprising roots of
the modern anti-vaxx movement but today
we wanted to go
in depth on one particular part of that
story
the media especially over the last few
years the media has postured themselves
as dispellers of misinformation
and that can be very true but
historically it's also been
pretty false like when the media helped
propel vaccines information into the
public consciousness not just once
but multiple times how does that happen
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on anti-vaxxers and the media
and before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
hover hover is an easy to use service
that allows you to create a custom
domain name or email address
if you're on the hunt for a new job you
want to put your best foot forward and
one of the first things people will see
is your email now as much as your 12
year old hotmail username might suit you
it might not cut it for the hiring
manager's first impression a domain and
email address speaks
volumes it makes it seem like you have
your life together your business could
also benefit from a custom address
because
now more than ever your online presence
matters hover will help you stand out
and grow your brand because you can
connect your custom domain to your
website or portfolio with a few simple
clicks they have over 400 domain name
extensions to choose from
including all the classics and fun niche
extensions you can start personalizing
your online brand
today go to hover.com wisecrack for 10
off your first purchase or click the
link in the description
once again that's hover.com wisecrack or
hit the link in the description now back
to the show
now for a quick disclaimer we're going
to be talking about the quote-unquote
debate about certain vaccines but it's
important to remember
that massive population level studies
have pretty conclusively proven that
vaccines a
do not cause autism and b are safe aside
from incredibly rare adverse events
which is all to say we'll be talking
about controversies today that
are not scientific controversies at all
we're also going to be talking a lot
about television news
because well it's visual but rest
assured the same problems that we will
discuss
exist in print all right enough
disclaimers let's start with a vaccine
scare that many credit for launching the
modern anti-vaccine movement in america
a 1982 documentary called dpt vaccine
roulette the special put forth the
concern that the pertussis or
whooping cough vaccine was causing
permanent brain damage in kids while the
vaccine was known to have more severe
side effects than other childhood
inoculations there was no
evidence that it caused any of the
long-term brain damage detailed in the
documentary it pit one supposed expert
against another all the while presenting
viewers with
heartbreaking images of parents caring
for their children despite
serious phrasing problems my grandsons
receive the d it would catalyze vaccine
fears and parents across the country and
spark the formation of anti-dpt vaccine
parent groups while the presenter won an
emmy for her reporting the journal of
the american medical association found
that the program was
rife with errors everything from
inflating the titles of the people they
interviewed to falsely reporting the
numbers of children who experienced side
effects from the vaccine now we're not
gonna cover why asking the question
why should i get vaccinated for diseases
like diphtheria or pertussis when no one
gets it anymore
is mind-numbingly dumb why are we giving
children
so many vaccines there's no more polio
in the united states and there's no more
diphtheria in the united states instead
we're going to divert our attention to
something else going on
both side-ism specifically how it
enabled bad science to infiltrate the
hearts and minds of
millions of americans no vaccine's ever
been proven safe and no vaccine has ever
been proven effective
both side-ism or false balance is a
phenomenon wherein a media outlet
portrays differing facets of a debate as
having equal merit when in reality
the factual evidence is strongly stacked
on one side
of course there are a lot of issues that
legitimately have multiple sides to
consider
like when different scientists try to
predict how many people will be infected
by or die from covet 19.
that's something good science
journalists cover it's a scientific
controversy where scientists disagree
which should be differentiated from
social controversies or
political controversies that is just
because something is up for debate in
the youtube comments
doesn't mean it's up for debate among
scientists whether that's the idea that
the earth is round or that vaccines
prevent deadly diseases
and dpt vaccine roulette seems like it's
presenting a scientific controversy with
experts in all
except well they had to fudge a few
numbers and titles to make that
controversy seem compelling in the first
place
in the years after the documentary's
release programming on the dpt vaccine
often used the language of empowering
the viewer to make their own choices
it's frightening so is it true you
decide and
this framing lent itself to a peculiar
imbalance in order to present the viewer
with two purportedly equal sides as
opposed to an
open and shut case of scientific
consensus the vaccine
critical claims were given a
disproportionate amount of airtime in
other words the media had to make the
anti-vaxx case seem more compelling than
it was
in order to justify airing these kinds
of programs to begin with
exposing people to scientific ideas that
scientists don't take seriously isn't
necessarily an intentionally nefarious
deed sometimes it simply comes from a
journalist's desire for
fairness they want to make sure both
sides get equal exposure
i don't want to get into which of these
stories are just cynical sensationalism
and which are earnest reporters trying
to do their jobs but regardless
sensationalism is a systemwide problem
in the media a story about a zesty
climate change tweet is more likely to
get clicks than a headline declaring
that the vast majority of scientists
agree
the anthropogenic climate change is a
real thing no really or it's follow-up
seriously stop asking us nothing has
changed
but both sides in an argument
dishonestly also happens to make
great conflict and conflict makes great
tv
after all there's a reason reality show
producers love casting people with poor
emotion regulation
and when it comes to good tv vaccines
have great conflict baked into them it
pits sympathetic mothers vs
cold doctors real americans versus the
medical establishment
emotions are bound to run high and most
importantly
it's got kids nothing draws attention
like
suffering children it makes for such
reliably good tv
that doctor vs mom is basically a genre
of its own within talk show segments we
dug up a bunch of these segments
starting with a 1986 episode of regis
philbin's the morning show on one side
were two mothers who claimed the dpt
shot harmed their children then there's
the director of a hospital pediatric
ward
after one mother whose child died tells
her story the doctor says
what's important is not to minimize the
tragedy
that you just heard about but it has to
be put in perspective
the mother inhales and blinks rapidly
she
looks like she's desperately trying to
keep it together of course factually the
doctor
is right danger from vaccine reactions
are far
overshadowed by the number of lives
saved but it sounds cold and callous to
spew public health statistics in the
face of a grieving mother the viewer is
just as likely to come away feeling rage
on the parents behalf
as they are to be reassured about the
efficacy of childhood vaccine schedules
here's another mother on cnn's sonja
live in 1990 debating the dpt vaccine
she appears to have the most
cutting-edge information on new
scientific studies
has memorized all the relevant numbers
and seemingly holds her own against the
doctor who she is debating
without relying on an emotional appeal
so who are we supposed to believe
we also pulled a 1995 segment with brian
gumbel about the chickenpox vaccine
where the host
after talking to an actual pediatrician
says there is
quote-unquote debate about the safety of
the vaccine
despite the fda's approval there is
still some debate over whether or not
the vaccine is really necessary or
completely safe
that's before cutting straight to the
other side as represented by a mother
who heads an official sounding
vaccine information organization gumball
also without any amount of journalistic
skepticism uncritically presents her as
you are one of many parents whose
children have suffered crippling
reactions to vaccines
also if she looks familiar it's because
she was in all three videos
her name is barbara lo fisher and she
was propelled to national attention
thanks in part to being an easy
source for the other side for new
segment producers even if the other side
in her case amounted to
pseudoscience as manukin writes barbara
lowe fisher who was oftentimes
identified in the press as a seemingly
impartial vaccine expert and as the head
of a parent advocacy group that fought
for children's health was relied on by
many reporters in need of a quick
reaction
the los angeles times even once listed
her organization as a source to learn
more about the subject but
let's get back to the 1980s and dpt
vaccine roulette the controversy angered
doctors across the country for
irresponsible reporting that stoked
unfounded vaccine fears so when a new
so-called controversy appeared over a
decade later
surely journalist and tv producers were
a little better equipped
right in 1998 andrew wakefield a british
medical researcher authored a paper that
warned of a link between the measles
mumps and rubella vaccine or mmr and
inflammatory bowel disease and autism
the argument
was that measles including the weakened
strain of measles in the vaccine
caused a leaky gut which in turn caused
autism there were a
boatload of problems with the study and
many seasoned science reporters ignored
the finding
but the anti-vaxx crowd repackaged the
story as a human interest piece to
non-science journalists who didn't have
the background to spot the study's red
flags thanks to the investigative work
of brian dear years later we now know
that lawyers involved in a vaccine
lawsuit paid wakefield
eight hundred thousand dollars for his
research and funneled him subjects for
the study he did
many other shady things which we don't
have time to get into
but by the end of it all dude lost his
medical license
anyway how did the media handle this
whole fiasco here's a clip from a 2001
episode of 60 minutes australia first we
hear from several parents with autistic
children who believe that the mmr dose
caused their autism we also hear from
andrew wakefield
who carefully explains his theory we
then hear from both a specialist in
infectious diseases and a senior
official in the british health
department who both dismiss wakefield's
conclusions as
bad medicine the studies simply do not
convey
the conclusions that dr wakefield
attaches to them despite
multiple experts weighing in to explain
that there is absolutely no
evidence of the mmr vaccine causing
autism i can tell you
tara that all the studies that have been
done show no link
we pan back to wakefield who hits us
with this doozy
now the fundamental rule of clinical
medicine is that you listen to the
patient
or the patient's parents and so when
they say to me i think this is mmr do we
take that seriously or not
damn right we do wakefield does a
masterful job of twisting the dialogue
from bad science versus good science to
patience versus pencil pushers and with
plenty of b-roll footage of children
damaged by vaccines 60 minutes seems to
help him make his case
philosopher alfred archer argues that by
giving significant attention to outsider
positions within the scientific
community journalists run the risk of
sending the message that expert opinion
on the issue is more evenly divided than
in fact is the case
in 2002 a bbc channel aired a special
called
mmr every parent's choice focusing on a
yet to be released paper by
none other than andrew wakefield again
it presented the controversy as though
it were a political battle between
beleaguered mothers and lofty
bureaucrats
the format is again designed to pull at
heartstrings
if we're talking about a can of beans
and sainsburys
that might possibly be contaminated the
whole lot would have been withdrawn by
now and we're talking about kids
lives here the problem of course is that
there was no
good quality evidence that the mmr
vaccine had anything to do with autism
there's no evidence that mmr vaccine
increases the likelihood
of autism at any time but instead of
pressing wakefield and the parents to
defend their claims
the bbc put the burden of proof on the
scientists who are working with decades
of international research
just because there is no evidence now
doesn't necessarily mean there won't be
evidence in the future
what happens if you've got it wrong this
isn't a situation
where we're in the dark with no evidence
whatsoever but
you're choosing to focus on one
or a small group of people's claims
everything from the title
every parent's choice to the time slip
between interviewees is designed to make
the special
look like it's presenting a fair and
balanced review of two equal sides but
the sides
aren't equal one has decades of
scientific research behind it and the
other has two studies both published by
a rogue doctor who has since been
accused of changing data from his lab
notebooks to fit the conclusion that he
wanted the bbc special triggered an
avalanche of parent verse doctor news
stories on the new mmr autism
controversy with the aid of wakefield
study
a few years later the mmr autism debacle
got a new celebrity boost
jenny mccarthy the former playboy
playmate mtv comedian and nbc sitcom
star blamed her son's autism on vaccines
in 2007 she released a book
louder than words a mother's journey in
healing autism and went on oprah to
promote it
and like the bbc special half a decade
earlier oprah's platform provided
crucial legitimation to mccarthy's
fringe views
once the seal had been broken so to
speak mccarthy started to be presented
as an
expert up for debate against
pediatricians and scientists
we do not need that many vaccines and
ready to show up on larry king
these doctors are not learning about
prevention or vitamins
media both side ism doesn't operate in a
vacuum it only works within an ecosystem
of
other fallacies and distortions that
help convey to the viewer that the
program is trying to impart an unbiased
message and most importantly let the
viewer choose what to believe but their
options for belief have already been
tampered with and the result is
real world epidemics like the 2019
measles outbreak in samoa that infected
more than 3 percent of the population
and killed
83 people the same year there were
nearly 700 cases of measles in the u.s
the highest since 2000 when the disease
was considered
eliminated in america earlier in the
decade measles surged in the uk when at
least a million children went
unvaccinated
dr david elleman spokesman of the royal
college of pediatrics and child health
said this is the legacy of the wakefield
scare
what's more there's research showing
that false balance really does shift
people's perception of the vaccine
debate
researchers found that during the
wakefield autism controversy in 2002 the
majority of people in britain
wrongly believed that doctors and
scientists were equally divided over the
safety of the mmr vaccine
that may be because 70 percent of news
stories related to mmr mentioned a link
with autism while only 11 percent
covered the vaccine safety record
the researchers wrote that 53 of those
surveyed at the height of the media
coverage of the issues
assumed that because both sides of the
debate received equal media coverage
there must be equal
evidence for each and those perceptions
aren't limited to a blip in the early
odds
i do really want to specify here this is
not a blanket attack on the media
science journalism is hard it involves a
ton of background knowledge on the
issues you're reporting on and talking
to experts in the fields to disentangle
incredibly complex topics journalists
also have everything working against
them they are chronically underpaid and
overworked leading some sites to more or
less just
copy and paste press releases without
the good critical commentary science
journalism should provide and
on the other end you have pressure to
reach more viewers or readers especially
for outlets supported by
advertising revenue but unfortunately
all these factors led us to a place
where people take
pseudoscientific fears way more
seriously than they should
and those memories of vaccine scares
whether from mmr dpt or others resurface
for many as they consider whether or not
to vaccinate their children or to get
vaccinated against covet 19.
many outlets have since grappled with
the flaws of both sides journalism
uncovering conspiracy theories
pseudoscience or just flat-out
misinformation coming from government
officials but
many have not but what do you think let
us know in the comments
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support obliterate that subscribe button
like you're a vaccine-induced anti-body
hunting for sars-ko v2 and don't forget
to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you